hi everyone i'm david griffin and i'm
michael medina we're here to bring you
this week's review of arrows the season
two episode two it's very appropriately
named identity uh this is kind of the
episode everybody trying to figure out
everybody's identity right now hence the
name uh
as uh it's great uh just some back and
forth between the island and now you
know we see uh um oliver trying to
rediscover himself in sterling's or
sorry starlight and try to pronounce
darling starling city uh
uh as a better guy the guy doesn't kill
people and then of course we see him on
the island we just uh you know just
killed somebody what do you think of
this week's episode um i enjoyed it i
thought it was good uh you know talking
about what you just said right now about
oliver and stuff i'm liking the struggle
that i'm saying because he is trying to
do right i mean not that he wasn't doing
right before but it's tough going from
like just being you know what's what's
seen as like a cold-blooded killer right
to actually trying to prove his worth
and trying to do something right and uh
yeah we're getting a little bit of i
feel like they're starting to flesh out
a few more of the other characters like
roy harper yep you know how he's
struggling to kind of build his
relationship with thea or speedy you
know and just trying to get that to work
while at the same time trying to kind of
work you know in the vigilantes shadow
you know and arrow hood whatever you
want to call them and stuff so yeah i'm
really liking what i'm seeing so far the
character development's really coming
along you know and i'm liking you know
how they're starting to not much but
kind of slowly build a little bit more
unlike what's going on with the island
so you're starting to see you know
initially how oliver started to turn
yeah you know just you starting to
really see some of those bad things that
he didn't want to talk about in season
one
things he's not proud of i like to uh uh
this well i think did a little bit
better i've only seen a you know
smallville
periodically i know you've watched
you've watched the whole run so you know
this better item but i realized that
smallville didn't introduce as many you
know the dc universe as i think some
people would have liked it seems like
daryl's doing if i'm crazy he's doing a
better job of that i mean with the
introduction of of course you see bronze
tiger in this week michael j white spawn
himself
that seemed good i feel like with
smallville they kind of trickled in a
few guys i felt like towards the
uh last few seasons and stuff they
started kind of opening up the dc
universe a little bit more you saw like
you know the legion of uh superheroes
and things like that and all this stuff
and that was really cool and i was
really happy to see that so um yeah but
i i like the fact that we're getting to
see some more people and some more
villains we've seen some smashed in
blood yeah blood so there's some
research and i both did some some
research on this and we learned that uh
mike i already knew this uh he actually
had a nice graphic novel collection of
teen titans yeah what year was that that
was back in the oh this is uh it's the
judas contract so this is like early 80s
and stuff so this guy i don't know i'm
sure it's not going to be quite as faint
he has this big red suit with like you
know just like you know all this grit
everything over the top it's not going
to be like that and we have this uh
actor uh mr uh last name's alejandra can
you remember his first name he's from
true true blood member for those of you
true blood fans out there and he's a bad
guy the only way you become i was
reading the history there's only become
the the brother blood or the head is uh
by committing an act of patricide you
actually have to kill your own dad to
get up to the top so this now i don't
know if they're gonna explain all that
but this guy's a bad dude absolutely i
mean i'm sure this [ __ ] was a little
more subtle so i feel like he's not
gonna be probably the more kind of evil
villain but no they're not gonna it's
nice to see him though it's great to see
him um i'm also again kind of like what
you're saying a little early about like
you know opening up the universe and
stuff which i'm all for but i'm also a
little worried like i don't want them to
try to do too much this season i like
that we're seeing you know brother blood
i like the fact that they're kind of
teasing you know black canary i just
hope that they kind of like you know
really take their time to again flesh
out these characters as well but i do i
was excited to see brother i mean they
had mentioned them in season in uh
episode one yeah so it'd be interesting
to see the route that they go with him
yeah i mean i think they're doing a
great job with the casting uh of course
this week we didn't see summer glau
she's not in here you know we got i'm
sure she'll kind of come in periodically
you know she's kind of co-running the
company but uh we did a little like he
said let's go back we're gonna go back
to roy a little bit and uh like the end
you know i mean
he is starting to become he's got his
heroes red arrow you know i mean the
whole red arrow stuff and some people
suggest that he might become arsenal i
don't know if they'll go quite that far
i mean maybe he will maybe he'll be more
into guns and stuff i don't know but if
he's learning from oliver hopefully
he'll be he won't try to kill people but
we'll see
i like that uh that moment at the end uh
we realized that he's probably gonna
keep doing what he's doing he's kind of
lying to a girl there you know he's not
gonna stop right he's not gonna yeah
he's right now he's focused he's hell
bent right on just kind of like you know
following you know arrows footsteps that
whole nice speech about oh i would
rather be with like quiet man like
you know you want to be a red arrow you
want to be the sidekick absolutely he's
a good guy at heart and he's he's kind
of a little like oliver too just a
different perspective he's a you know
his kid from the glades and he's you
know kind of had a rough childhood and
stuff and he's trying to also do right
trying to make himself better and stuff
he's you know young he's a librarian but
yeah he'll get there and then of course
you have to look at the the very end
with uh you know i mean oliver got
messed up this week i mean he got shot
he got stabbed one time by uh you know
uh bronze tiger i mean so i like at the
end though we see him confronted by
laurel laurel
had his little magic button all the cops
came in so i mean how is he gonna get
out of this one
is he gonna make it what's he gonna do
until next week because i mean obviously
the show is going to go on we know he's
going to be okay but i want to be
curious next week to see how he gets out
of this it looks like from the preview
next week we're going to see some more
of oliver's mom yeah and her story
developed so i mean i think the story is
moving along well i'm like yeah i think
it is too and kind of again with laurel
and stuff and i'm all for obviously he's
having a rough time he's still seen as a
vigilante i get that i just hope they
don't i feel like it's a little bit more
the same like with last season it was
laurel's dad that was hell bent on yeah
and now i feel like it's laurel again
that's fine i just hope that they don't
kind of drag that along because it's
just basically going to be like season
one all over again but instead of she
she's basically like the new merlin i
was like i see you as a murderer all
that so hopefully i don't yeah and i
wonder if he'll reveal himself to her
this season or next season i don't know
what's gonna happen i mean it's it's
still a good show it's action-packed
it's moving forward i love the
instruction new characters i mean you
know of course you know let us know what
you think uh you know what are your
thoughts on you know sebastian butler
any teen titan fans you're reading the
old school teen titans stories what do
you think about him joining the universe
and of course we've got a glimpse of
black canary yeah
if you want to probably just up in the
comments there are some spoilers as to
who black canary actually is on imdb i
won't reveal it here just because if you
want to just have it fresh stay off imdb
stay off the chat
away from me they've already announced
who the casting is it's kind of annoying
like you know who it is there's no
suspense but just avoid that so
hopefully we see some more black canary
as the episodes i'm excited excited for
the city city of heroes
i think that's probably going to be the
overall theme of the season
of heroes and then we'll see what
happens in later but another great
episode so you know as always come you
know let us know what you think you can
come uh chat with us over at
thinkhero.com or of course you know on
this youtube channel at thinkheropro uh
we're also on twitter uh myself and uh
michael and i uh we're on think here
we've talked to all of us went to dennis
me or anyone else personally i'm at
griffinde and i'm a mr michael alexis
and we also have a facebook page that's
facebook.com think hero fans
you